ههه ضجه وسائل الاعلام في اندونيسيا من
ايام بفيديو لرجل بينهض من الموت فيعني
عنوان غريب طبعا بس انا ما رح اقول لكم
تفاصيل القصه الا بعد ما تشوفوا بنفسكم
الفيديو
انتبهتوا كيف يعني الرجل رجوله وجسم تتحرك
والممرضين يعني تجمدوا كده في مكانه ممنوع
عرفين ايش يسووا يعني المفروض هذه جثه
واخذاها على ثلاجه الموت يعني شوفوا بالله
مره كمان رده فعلهم المساكين
شكرا
اذا عرف السبب يعني انه بطل العجب واا
الرجال اللي المفروض ميت طلع اصلا مميز
كده لا طلع هو بذات نفسه اللي مفبرك موضوع
موته انا عارفه تتصدق بس يعني استنوا
تفسيرها وحتتصدموا اكثر من يعني بنكمل
الابتكار والابداع في الموضوع فهذا الرجال
على اليوتيوب كثير وما قادر يدفعها فقرر
هو ومرته قصه تموت واستاجر سياره اسعاف
وتابوت وجابوا الرجال يحطوه في نصف ساعه
في القريه
وترحموا وكل شيء على امل انه يعني موته
خلاص
بطوط
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
يكملوا الموضوع لانه ببساطه اللي صار لانه
بعدها شالت الناس الجثه للمستشفى عشان
الاجراءات وتدفن وهناك عاد انصدموا عايش
وعموم من الديون هيدفعها يعني هيدفعها
وفوق كل هذا الشرطه فتحت تحقيق واحتمال
ينسجن كمان على عمته وطبعا في احتمال
يتعاقب كمان ويسجن يعني عام همم بخلينا
تحديد نقول انه ممكن همم
النكت اللي هتطلع عليه يعني
[موسيقى]